il faut qu'on leur tend à produire selon
mr johnson regarde ça ça c'est une
brésilienne qui vit en suède au départ
devait faire les jeux olympiques pour la
suède et puis finalement à s'affaiblir
et du coup elle a décidé de faire un jeu
au pied pour son autre pays le brésil et
ses combats non ton père est algérien
ouais donc toi aussi ouais ça m'as tu
vas faire les jeux olympiques pour
l'algérie en ski de fond ça donne une
idée ouais ok et tu sais quoi si je
pouvais je laisserais légion ah ouais
sauf que moi j'ai aucune chance de me
qualifier toit en revanche tu es le seul
algérien
enfin sur la neige je veux dire tu es
sûr de se qualifier puisque façon
rappelle toi au ski et tutus cartonné
c'était 25 ans 9 25 ans samedi
on a tout fait lors tout est prêt la pub
les skis pour durer une semaine le
marketing
alors tu va le remplacer et puis c'est
tout les jeux olympiques
ouais et tu vois c'est là où tu te
goures parce qu'à un algérien sur des
skis mais c'est moins une fois mieux car
suédois voulons tout savoir